we're told Martha has a fixed budget of
$20 and she spends it all on to goods
good exid good why the price of x is $4
per unit and the price of y is $2 per
unit the table below shows the total
benefit measured in dollars
Martha receives from the consumption of
each good all right we see that here
this is total benefit not marginal
benefit what is Martha's marginal
benefit of the fifth unit of good-x so
just to answer this question let's see
she has a total benefit of $40 when she
has four of X and then when she goes to
the fifth her total benefit is an
incremental $1 so she goes from $40 to
$41 the marginal benefit of that fifth
one is that extra dollar so we added a
dollar of total benefit so that's the
marginal benefit so it is one dollar
calculate the total consumer surplus if
Martha consumes five units of X show
your work well the consumer surplus is
going to be the benefit benefit minus
the cost which is going to be equal to
well when she has five units of X her
total benefit is $41 so I'll write that
here forty one dollars and then what's
her cost of five units of X well X costs
four dollars per unit so five times four
is 20 dollars so our cost is going to be
$20
so her consumer surplus is going to be
equal to $21 martha is currently
consuming four units of x and two units
of Y use marginal analysis to explain
why this combination is not optimal for
Martha so pause this video and see if
you can answer that all right well let's
just think about what the marginal
benefit is from every incremental unit
of X or Y and then let's think about the
marginal benefit per dollar so I'm going
to make an extra column here let's call
this marginal benefit of X and then
let's call this marginal benefit of why
I'm doing it over this table just for
the sake of space and so the marginal
benefit of
this first one is going to be 16 we went
from 0 to 16 the second one we go from
16 to 28 so it's $12 and then to go from
28 to 36 is 8 to go from 36 to 40 is 4
extra dollars of benefit and to go from
40 to 41 we already talked about that
that's one dollar of marginal benefit if
we talk about why well the first unit
you get 10 dollars a benefit the next
one is the total benefit increase 8 by 8
dollars so that's the marginal benefit
of the next unit the next one to go from
18 to 24 6 to go from 24 to 28 is 4 more
and then 28 to 30 is 2 more and then we
could use this information to think
about marginal benefit of X per price of
X and we could also think about marginal
benefit of y per price of Y and so let's
see and we're going to start with the
first units and so for this first unit
if you take the marginal benefit of X
divided by the cost of unit of X 16
dollars divided by 4 dollars is going to
get for 12 divided by 4 is 3 8 divided
by 4 is 2 4 divided by 4 is 1 and 1/4 is
0.25 and then for y the cost of y is $2
per unit so the marginal benefit benefit
per dollar of this first unit right over
here is $10 divided by $2 which is 5 8
divided by 2 is 4 6 divided by 2 is 3 4
divided by 2 is 2 and then 2 divided by
2 is 1 and so let's just think about
what would be an optimal combination for
martha when she's thinking about
spending her first few dollars she'll
get a higher marginal benefit per dollar
by going with y so she's going to start
here and then after that her second unit
of y has the same marginal benefit per
dollar as our first unit of x so she's
indifferent she would do these in some
order so maybe she could do this one and
then move on to that one or though it
could go in the other order and so far
she's only spent let's see two dollars
two dollars is four dollars plus another
4 now she's only spent eight dollars and
she has a budget of 20 and then after
that her next incremental
the unit of either X or Y the marginal
benefit per dollar is the same so just
thinking about whether this could be an
optimal combination
she's already bought two units of Y
let's just give the benefit of the doubt
here let's say that she goes for the X
so she buys this one here but once she
has two units of both and she hasn't
spent all of her money she spent eight
dollars here plus another four dollars
she has eight dollars to spend the next
rational thing for her to do her
marginal benefit per dollar for that
third incremental y is higher than the
third incremental X so it would be
optimal for her to buy a third y but
here we see that she only has two units
of Y so that's why we know it's not an
optimal combination
so we could say once she has two of each
the marginal benefit of y per price of y
is greater than the marginal benefit of
X per price of X for the third unit so
she will buy more than two y's let me
write let me scroll down a little bit
buy more than two y's all right
the next they say is what is the what is
Martha's optimal combination of goods of
x and y well we've already started that
conversation up here she would buy this
y and so far she spent eight dollars
plus six dollars so she says another six
dollars to spend and then now her next
incremental unit she's indifferent so
maybe she buys another y eight dollars
plus eight dollars this is sixteen
dollars so she has four dollars left and
so then she would buy this and she has
spent all of her money she's twelve
dollars here eight dollars here so she
would buy three x's and four wise so I
would say three x's and four Y's all
right part e indicate whether each of
the following will cause the optimal
quantity of good Y to increase decrease
or stay the
same so look at these and pause this
video and see if you can answer those so
the price of good-y doubles well if the
price of good-y doubles then the
marginal benefit / price of Y will go
down so she will buy less of Y so it
would decrease she would get less bang
for her buck on Y it's issued by less of
Y martha's income Falls to $10 with no
price changes well if we go through the
exercise we just did her budget would
run out much faster and so she would
definitely decrease the number of Y's
she would buy so the Y's would decrease
Martha's income doubles and the price of
good both good its double well in that
case things would stay the same stay the
same because well it's again she could
buy that exact same combination it would
just cost twice as much but then her
budget is now twice as much so things
would stay the same should buy the same
quantities of both X's and Y's and
they're just asking about y's and we're
done